hey lynn
hi welcome back
so you've been gone
for quite a while
where have you been
uh i was in jail for a year
and just got out a few months ago
this was the assault case that got you
in trouble
uh yeah
you did how much time one year one year
that's why we haven't seen you yeah yeah
how's jail
um
it was pretty tough but i got through it
about three quarters of the way it was
tough and then a quarter of the way um
i've learned a lot
in jail
yeah that's that's what i've seen with a
lot of people that i've interviewed
who've done prison time
or jail
is that they they just mature
yeah they grow up a little bit you
you're getting a lot of time to think
about your life and what you've done and
what you're doing
is that what happened with you
oh yeah
learned a lot of patience
are you still angry
no
i think you i think you have a lot of
anger like a lot of people do we all do
hidden away
somewhere probably at your mom
do you talk to your mom
uh yeah we're getting along well you are
that's great
that's great
so where are you now where are you
staying
um
in los angeles but are you homeless or
yeah i'm in a shelter i'm trying to get
my social security income back
what are your plans
um
[Music]
either to stay here or to go
back to florida
probably just visit for a month or
something
do you have any plans any dreams
anything you'd like to do
um
no
not yet i mean i want to get actually i
do i want to get into cosmetology
or some type of college
i'd like to get into college for um
it's like psychology it'd be great yeah
i could see you doing that
so being in jail for a year
that'll
that'll stop you from using crystal meth
right yeah how was that
um
it was
really easy actually
because
my mind was so focused on
like what was outside of the door
because i was in an isolated cell
the whole time
um i had a lot of alone time to think
why were you in an isolated cell
um
because the first time i was in jail
they um
i yelled at somebody
and then they put me in an isolated cell
and then i went back to jail
and they kept me in an isolated cell
so you're you're by yourself the
for most of the year
um
yeah
[Music]
yeah there was there's a program
in there called the life program that i
was in
uh it's basically just to um
acclimate back into
population
was there any mental health
um
considerations with your case
mental health
there was there were groups
but
nothing in depth
yeah i just wonder if some medications
or something like that might be
described
yeah
does it do you do get some kind of
treatment i did yeah yeah i did
and you're still taking that
um no no i'm not on medications right
now
did they help but they
i can't really tell a difference
but
i've been doing pretty good without them
how do you think you've changed since
the first time i met you
i've met or i've learned patience
um
a lot of patients
psychology
you're how old now twenty-seven
three quarters
so you you're getting along with your
mom
what do you guys talk about
any kind of forgiveness or anything like
that no no just you just deal with each
other
we both basically just talk about um
regular everyday things
like home life and
how we're doing can you imagine staying
with her if you move back to florida uh
probably not i'll get my own place yeah
yeah you're old enough for that yeah
and you've been out for how long a month
a few months a few months yeah
how was the
shelter uh it's pretty awesome actually
um
they supply me with my needs
so
how do you think you ended up homeless
in the first place what do you think
went
[Music]
what caused your situation when i first
met you coming to california
it seems to do that to a lot of people
yeah
yeah
um that was tough
it is
what's your
what's your biggest regret at this point
in your life
um i'd have to say the
drugs that i was on whenever i did the
adw
adw is the assault yes yeah
i saw it with a deadly weapon what was
your weapon again
um a switchblade
and you you
assaulted a woman that worked there or
that was there
i did
but that's not the reason i was in jail
i was in jail for a warrant
i missed a court date
so the court date is the missed court
date is what got you in jail
yeah not the actual assault correct it's
interesting how the courts work
do you think there's any chance of that
happening again with you
no
the salt no because i'm completely clean
now i don't
think about drugs i don't do drugs i
don't
i mean they've been offered to me but
mentally my first thought is no
and then my
second thought is no
so
it's a bit on the line of psychology
so
if i were to want the drugs
and that my first thought was yes and
then i said no
then i'd still be craving it but at this
point it's no
so that's good and do you credit just
the time
of isolation in jail that kind of helped
you see it differently
um what was that i mean do you think
spending the time a year in prison
in jail where you were isolated and
unable to get your drug kind of helped
you see things more clearly
um or differently
no
why do you think your attitude about
crystal meth has changed
um
i mean it's really not a need to me you
know
it's not
a necessity
so
technically my attitude towards it
isn't really
there like i don't really have an
attitude towards it because i never
think about it i'm sure your brain
chemistry has
come back to normal now because you've
not used
my natural dopamine has
come back that's what i mean yeah
what would you like to see what would
you like to see happen you mentioned
what you like to do but
in life yeah just in life like
um
i'd like to go to school for psychology
or cosmetology
or both yeah
but if i go to school for psychology it
might take a really long time and i have
learned patience but
i feel that if i learn the basics
which i kind of already know
it'll get mixed up with my natural
psychology and
i just don't
i don't know
what kind of emotions do you go through
now that you're clean
and free
emotions because you were like when some
of the earlier talks you were you were
very angry and
a little unstable it seemed
emotions
i mean do you find yourself getting
depressed right now or are you angry or
are you anxious are you
like in the shelter or just in general
just in general
the last few months since you've been
free
i would have to say that i'm
not really
in a negative
mindset
it's great it's more positive than
negative
that's important
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned at this point in
your life
um
everything takes time
it's a good one
because as a child and as a teenager i
was very impatient
um
[Music]
and now i'm a lot more patient
do you have any friends
no
no
it's amazing how many people i interview
who have the same
answer to that
question almost everybody it seems
tells you they don't have any friends
yeah
and tell me about your dad again was he
ever in your life
am i biological yeah
he was for a little bit
but he's passed away
i'm sorry
mistakes
do you look back at your life and wish
you hadn't made
or did you just look at them as
learning
as lessons that you needed
i say uh
learning yeah we all make mistakes
it's part of growing up yeah
you like los angeles
yeah
for the most part
is there anything else you want to talk
about that we didn't i can edit this
together
um
not that i can think of
[Music]
are you lonely
only yeah no
no
[Laughter]
you feel misunderstood by people around
you people in your life
i don't because i don't really expect
them to understand
i guess
i mean there really is nothing to
understand
are you not as complex as you appear as
you seem
you seem pretty complex
what does a complex mean just
complicated you you don't seem like an
easy person to get to know and friendly
with and
actually i'm very easy to get to know
i am i just don't really talk to a lot
of people because i have autism
was that right
we never talked about that before
yeah i have a lot of mental illnesses
but they don't clash they all get along
so
tell me about drug use since you've been
out have you used it all
no
um
i actually after the
hospitalizations that i was in i had
overdosed
on seroquel
seroquel is one of the medications they
one of the psych medications yes and you
overdosed on seroquel yeah how do you do
that you seek too many
um
i did that about a month ago
that was intentional or by mistake or
intentional
really
i felt that um
my whole life was just
worthless and
but
still trying to
stay on the positive side
um
i'm happy that i did not die
you had mentioned that you were suicidal
in that very first talk
when i mentioned
i mean i was at the time but this time
around it's just like
i felt
i guess you could say after the
overdose
after the overdose i
um
[Music]
after the overdose i just kind of
looked at the more positive side
those dark thoughts have they been a
constant with you throughout your life
um
or your adult life
they weren't really
i don't know
i don't know
do you like seeing a therapist have you
done it you've done that before
no no because my whole childhood i dealt
with everything on my own
you feel like you're you are your own
therapist
maybe yeah
it's always good to talk about stuff
just to get it out yeah
in the light
all right lynn well thank you so much
for
coming back and visiting me
i wish you the best of luck with uh
where you go from here all right thank
you thank you very much thanks
you